another thing Dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation no playing  chicken playing chicken is defined as a  test of courage in which two parties  engage in mutual challenges waiting for  the other person to back down first Dr  Bright's version of chicken tends to  involve climbing onto  scp-682's back during one of his  colleagues to climb atop another  dangerous SCP and ride them towards each  other to quote see what happens this is  strictly prohibited and Dr bright is no  longer allowed to play chicken with any  department at the foundation don't say  yes if he asks you to play chicken don't  even agree if he offers you some fried  chicken who knows what he's up to